JUST AN INCREDIBLE PERFORMANCE.
HIS EFFORT.
42 MINUTES.
HE LEFT IT ALL ON THE FLOOR.
BUT JUST NOT ENOUGH AGAINST
KEVIN DURANT AND THESE NETS.
>> Marv: SHAMET IS A GOOD FOUL
SHOOTER.
86% DURING THE REGULAR SEASON.
>> Grant: I'M STUNNED RIGHT NOW,
MARV.
I MEAN, MILWAUKEE WAS IN CONTROL
AND THEN KEVIN DURANT TOOK OVER
WITH A LEGENDARY PLAYOFF
PERFORMANCE.
JUST INCREDIBLE.
>> Marv: SO THE NETS BOUNCE BACK
FROM THE SUNDAY AFTERNOON LOSS
IN MILWAUKEE.
THE NETS NOW LEAD THIS BEST OF
SEVEN THREE GAMES TO TWO.
GAME SIX BACK IN MILWAUKEE
THURSDAY NIGHT.
BROOKLYN TRAILED BY AS MANY AS
17 POINTS WITH JUST UNDER 7:00
REMAINING IN THE THIRD QUARTER.
AND THEY OUTSCORED THE BUCKS BY
23 AFTER THAT.
>> Grant: I MEAN, IT'S
INCREDIBLE.
I KEEP SAYING THAT, BUT IT IS.
THE THING YOU WORRY ABOUT GOING
BACK TO GAME SIX,